this is a series of questions that are
really all trying to fit together so the
real question is part four that's the
real question but obviously if all I
gave you was that you wouldn't even know
where to begin so I'm just trying to
give you stepping stones or the HSC is
trying to give you stepping stones to
help you get there
so big is nice and easy they ask you for
a similarity proof okay correct so you
can always recognize HSE sort of
formatting it looks like it so I want
you to have a look at the way that I've
constructed my proof this is this is my
I'll leave it there this is my
similarity proof sorry good hi there you
go so when you're going for similarity
there are often many ways that you could
do similarity in fact the first time I
did this question I had a whole
different approach to it I was like why
am I doing this way it's so much more of
pain I was actually looking the sides
you know those isosceles triangles there
so you can if you so choose you can talk
about the proportions of the sides being
in the same proportion because because
they are however that's a very
inefficient and long-winded way to go
about it I realized about a half way
through the question I just talk about
angles because you only need two angles
you only need a pair and then you're
done
that's equiangular right so you've got a
common angle this guy right here in the
corner this guy here exists in both ABC
and a CD so you can see that as well and
then I only need one other angle so you
can see the way that I chose to do it I
notice that C ad and ACD are in that
small isosceles triangle at the top but
C ad is also because it's that common
angle it's also in the big isosceles
triangle do you know that see that so
therefore I can connect these two groups
that's not what I wanted to do I can
connect these two angles here because
they're both equal to C ad and that's
what I've done at this line here okay so
sorry I should move that up for you so
once I've got those two angles I've done
its equiangular okay now I want to give
you a bit of a trick how many people got
to part two hands up you got to part two
who got did you did anyone get part two
out yes
okay that's right good job let me let me
show you they're really trying to help
you out they are really really trying to
help you out number one even if you kind
of cannot get this you can use this
result to do the next thing even if you
can't prove it yourself okay but
secondly being that it is there it's
trying to give you a clue okay you just
proved that ABC is similar to a CD so
you have this similarity up your sleeve
and part two is going to sort of lean
into that similarity how can you use it
I want you to look carefully at this
line okay now what I'm about to do is
not the answer but it's a way that you
can get some idea of how to get to the
answer quicker when you've got Scylla
triangles what can you say about the
sides and Scylla triangles so you say
they're equal you can't say they're
equal you can say they're in ratio or in
proportion right so in other words
you're going to get something like this
you know random letters p on 2 equals r
on s that's a proportionality statement
then you've got the ratios you can see
them so all that matters is you just got
to work out what P Q R and s should be
and where they belong
now can you see it's actually not that
hard to reverse engineer out of this
statement what P Q R and s should be did
you see that
for instance what is X X inside of the
triangle right
okay parasites and triangles at it oh
here well that x squared probably came
from an X being on the left hand side
and an X being or the opposite
denominator can you see that do you see
that would be the immediately previous
line to writing x squared because you
would cross multiply in the same way
what do you think a squared plus ay Y
comes from what are the two bits that
have gone together you've got a and then
you've got a plus y like you need both
of those and look here's a there he is
and here is a plus y can you see that so
which one corresponds to which where is
which side does X in on the left-hand
side say this guy which one is that
correspond to
now I've actually given you a hand a
little bit can you see this diagram on
the right hand side I have I've put some
colors on here I've said this before and
I'll say it again colors are a super
power because they help you sift out
what's the important information in one
of the relationships in the diagram so
can you see I have drawn you've got the
two red I saw four equal sides and then
you've got the not equal so right but
this triangle corresponds to the bigger
triangle the ABC right except for ABC
these are the equal sides and this is
the not equal sign do you see that so
therefore if I add on to here look this
guy's X and this is a plus y over here
do you agree those are both the blue
sides the non-equal ones they're the
ones that correspond does that make
sense and then you can fill that in so
this is the line that's in my head or on
the side of my working it's something
else are because you don't know this is
true yet because that's the question but
now at least I know where my brain is
going so I just need to leg out which
sides are which so here's what my proof
looks like there you go like that can
you read it so I know this is where I'm
going to go this is where I'm going to
end up I clearly a squared plus ay Y
comes from having multiplied a plus y by
a and then you can see here is the line
that I had written down earlier as my
sort of reverse-engineered way of
thinking about the fact that they've
given me a clue I might want to use it
don't feel guilty for me yet we gave it
to you on purpose so use it the
trickiest part is you've got to work out
which side is X because there are two
x's right and which side is a because
there are also two sides that are equal
to a so you just got to know which ones
which and just look at your diagram
carefully will tell you this is the
order okay don't forget your region here
oh that's pretty important okay now I
will come back to this so and you can
take a picture and I kind of thing in a
minute but just why I still have your
attention I again want you to look at
the next line and I want you to read the
question carefully don't worry I promise
I'll come back to this and you can write
down
I be very conscious by the way I can
show you the answer for part three and
you will not learn as much as if you
think hard about part three before you
see the answer because of course once
you see an author it's like seeing a
puzzle that's been put together yo
obviously that is what it is right how
am I going to get to a statement about
this from a statement about this have a
look at the difference between part two
and part three there's a lot in common
but there's one particular thing that's
changed what's the difference okay so
the car theater just kind of stands out
well it where'd that come from right not
only has a college theater appeared but
something has disappeared do you notice
that what's disappeared the x-squared is
gone okay so that's a signal to you I
need to get x squared in terms of some
other stuff so I can substitute it away
so that the next line will no longer
have x squared in it does that make
sense so have a look at this triangle
you can see my diagrams got pretty busy
which is just another reason why you
should draw your own line have a look at
X how could you make a statement about X
that has to do with theta